christoph is with us in los angeles how
christoph how are you
better than i deserve how are you doing
mr anthony just the same sir how can i
help
well i'm a fourth year medical student
about to start residency actually in
nashville in one month
um i have a hundred thousand dollars in
medical debt um and based on what i'm
training to do i'll be a medical
resident for the next six or seven years
making 60 to 70k per year
however when i'm done training and
become an attending physician i'll be
making
330 to 500k my question is
with the knowledge that i can easily you
know more easily write a check for a
hundred thousand dollars
in you know seven or eight years should
i make minimum payments
now to be able to live comfortably such
as living close to work having my own
apartment versus having roommates
uh do you think that i'll be you know in
an intense uh
residency program working 80 hours a
week or should i be
really aggressive right now at the
expense of being able to live more
comfortably
[Music]
man off top of my head i'm gonna tell
you to be real aggressive right now i
don't know what the world's gonna look
like in eight years man
yeah i would get it i agree i'll get it
off of me
and here's the thing here's what's
running through my head
it let's pretend that you just called me
up and you said i make seventy thousand
dollars a year
and i have a hundred thousand dollars in
student loan debt
and that's all you said and that's all
it was because there wasn't a three
hundred thirty thousand dollar job out
there
you made seventy thousand dollars a year
and you had a hundred thousand dollars
in student loan debt
uh i would tell you paid off in three
years
beans and rice rice and beans and work
your way through it and i don't know why
you can't do that in this situation
um you know and uh
yeah you're you may have a roommate
situation you are
an inexpensive property that you're
living in but if you made seventy
thousand dollars a year and a hundred
thousand dollars worth of student loan
debt that's what you would do anyway
so that's not different the only thing
that's different is you are in a high
stress high pressure cooker situation as
a resident so
and 80 like you said 80 hours a week so
no opportunity to make any more
you are stuck with that income but the
payoff
and you do have this payoff at the end
but yeah i'm going to go ahead and clear
it
it's going to take you two and a half to
three years to clear it but i'm going to
go ahead and clear it because that's how
i'm going to treat it
is this if you're just made 70 grand and
you had 100 what would you do well you'd
pay it off
and i'm going to tell you something it's
going to sound counterintuitive i've
done some
research on med student mental health
and in fact i'm going to speak to med
school here in the fall
i would lean towards not
living what you would call a solitary
life where you work 80 hours and you go
by yourself into a home
and you can just you can shut everything
down i would actually especially in your
first couple years of residency
i want you leaning in and having some
friends i'd recommend have some
roommates man have some people you can
go home to
and that can be with you and be a human
with you
one of the biggest challenge that
medical residents have is this becomes
their planet their universe and it is
dealing with other people's pain and
trauma
all day long 24 7 365 and no sleeping
grab a
grab a granola bar on the way to the
next thing and the next thing
hey man there's something about being
tethered back to a group of people i
tell you to live light man people that
you're not treating
yeah i tell you to live light have a
group of people that you're sharing life
with
that's not gonna sound like i'm in
residency i'm a doctor i'd say have a
house full of roommates get this debt
paid off and then you're gonna look up
three or four years later
you're gonna be living a lot lighter man
then you can make some different
decisions